[Musique]
c'était un départ réclamé par les
maliens depuis des mois le président
keita a été renversé mardi par un coup
d'état après une mutinerie
les militaires du comité national pour
le salut du peuple qui ont pris le
pouvoir à bamako affirme vouloir mettre
en oeuvre une transition politique qui
débouchera sur des élections il fallait
faire quelque chose et on s'est retrouvé
dans une situation on pourrait faire
quelque chose et on a fait quelque chose
comme un pays c'est n'a pas fait ça
vient juste de commencer le reste du
travail à un temps là on a commencé
quelque chose les frustrations a fini
avec l'aide de tout le monde et faut que
ça soit fini
il faut que la démocratie soit revue que
ça réponde aux attentes du peuple et que
plus jamais on se retourne dans la
situation exceptionnelle mais les
dirigeants de la cedeao réunis lors d'un
sommet jeudi craignent que la mutinerie
ne déstabilise davantage le pays
ils exigent le rétablissement du
président déchu et menace les mutins de
différentes sanctions
le mallié dans une situation critique
avec des risques graves qu un
affaissement de l'état et des
institutions n'entraîne des revers dans
la lutte contre le terrorisme et le
crime organisé
mais ce que craignent plus encore les
pays d'afrique de l'ouest
c'est que ce vent de contestation ne
fasse tache d'huile dans la région comme
en guinée ou encore en côte d'ivoire où
les présidents alpha condé et alassane
ouattara brigue un troisième mandat
malgré l'opposition d'une grande partie
de la population au lendemain du
renversement du pouvoir au mali le
gouvernement ivoirien a interdit les
manifestations sur la voie publique
jusqu'au 15 septembre
une décision qui intervient une semaine
après les protestations qui ont fait au
moins six morts dans plusieurs villes du
pays
l'opposition ivoirienne conteste la
candidature du président de 78 temps
alassane ouattara à l'élection prévue en
octobre prochain
et c'est depuis ce matin comme pour la
marche assure nous sommes fatigués de
ouattara ne voulons pas un troisième
mandat
pour l'heure le président ivoirien
condamne fermement le soulèvement
militaire au mali et refuse de parler
d'un coup d'état réussi
nous devons agir avec détermination afin
d'obtenir par tous les moyens le
rétablissement de l'ordre
constitutionnel au mali même son de
cloche à quelques kilomètres de là en
guinée la cedeao se dit préoccupée par
les conditions de la tenue de l'élection
d'octobre prochain
alpha condé au pouvoir depuis 2010 est
notamment accusé par ses opposants
d'avoir plongé son pays dans la crise
pour rester au pouvoir et briguer
ensuite un nouveau mandat le soulèvement
populaire malien pourrait inspirer
l'opposition guinéenne qui se dit
ouverte au dialogue mais refuse
catégoriquement un troisième mandat du
président sortant